we're doing it
hello everyone
hold up gosh
we are back shouty
we back baby back in the studio
in this stupid i think that's what they
call it that's what the
youngins call it in the stew baby the
cool peeps call it
cool peeps
no cap i'm just using that i don't even
know what that means
[Laughter]
you're using terms like that is
hilarious i just love i love i have to
coach you up on those types of things
no flex no lie
no lie okay like no lie yeah yeah yeah
no flex i described it
that was funny i described it in another
confusing way no cap means no flex fam
duh
sorry i'm just trying to edit
the title for some reason the title of
the video came up as like a a right tin
club and i'm trying to edit the
description
yeah get that right get that right um
yeah everybody's talking about r.i.p
though but god for yeah man that's sad
dude
i know that like just happened too this
happened
it goes so i have to go i have seen
gilbert godfrey in
at a comedy club
oh yeah
and
he is
a monster
at the club
like
because he's such a
he's a he's very much like
either does one liners or he does long
story builds to get to amazing punch
lines
he's almost like
the uh
he's almost like an old school
jesselnick and i know that's kind of
disrespectful because gilbert gaffrey
kind of
is like an original
but basically like
that kind of storyteller where he's
telling long bits
of stuff
and then he hits you with that amazing
punchline at the end and it's just
completely worth it like
he knows for sure that the punchline
is the thing
and it works
well i mean that's that's the whole
thing he did with like the aristocrats
is it's like a long drawn-out joke where
you just basically say the grossest
most absurd things possible and then
um
the punchline they're calling it the
aristocrats
yeah
as as tavis said he said you and i
should do a version of the aristocrats
mine would be like a clean version i
guess um
oh and yeah j-lag in here and mookie
steve and fred sup fred
steve said the title's wrong yeah
sorry it's not perfect
sorry i had covered
oh you're still using that one
i'm going to use that for the next month
nah technology
nah i can't
i had coat i had covered did you hear
it's like so late i got it so late
well i thought it was late but clearly
it's still out there and well
oh it's it's it's thriving as the people
of philadelphia
oh i have i hadn't even like legit like
an la dude like it was like
it didn't even exist like honestly oh
yeah
yeah yeah i mean yeah philadelphia just
uh
imposed indoor mask mandates again
because they're seeing a rise
and it was no joke like i don't know if
it was different like
because i'm i'm vax to the max you know
i'm i'm boosted shouty like we out here
max's baby
and it was like it was no uh it was no
joke dude like i'm still not like a
hundred percent i'm definitely
much better but i'm still not like a
hundred percent and i'm like
i i did every i did all the boosts and
the vax's and
yeah yeah
it happens i mean it's
it's it's something that we're still
learning about you mean it's not like
exactly you know
you mean so yeah it's
so big you do be careful out there be
safe out in these comedy streets streets
it is no joke but it was worth it as
someone commented
oh and
nietzsche's muse said thanks for
interviewing comedians to inspire us
comedian wannabes
uh for sure
of course thanks for watching we
couldn't do it without you i heard i
heard from someone from venezuela today
oh nice
who's a fan of the podcast this is wild
did you speak spanish to him
no but he was actually reaching out
saying
things are getting really desperate over
there and he
he like offered to like teach me uh
spanish
if i could like and like like hire him
to teach me spanish basically because
he's like
it's he said it's getting really
desperate over there and they're
so he's basically trying to find new
ways to make money so
for sure dude that's that's what my
people do
you know what i mean oh so you think
it's not real if it's nigerian email you
think
i'm just saying i've i've heard this
script before
oh really
i didn't know oh okay i believe
i was like damn
sorry steve i'm trying to edit the title
for some reason
like both youtubes
i open them up in two different browsers
and both of them are just like they just
do in the circle wheel
oh
it's like
is that a t is is
maybe 18 t got coveted yeah
maybe that's what it is
dang
hilarious
it doesn't usually do that in chrome
though i don't understand
this is it's slightly annoying but i
guess it doesn't
technically matter
what is it
uh it just says the wrong show
title
yeah it may i mean it just says
um
it's like
it's the pre-filler i did for the last
live right tin club i did oh here we go
so
dang it
almost did you almost get it you almost
get it i finally got logged in
but hey everyone come on in
uh
welcome to hot breath live we're gonna
be doing some joke feedback today
yes um
we're gonna talk about
ti gosh i would really love to get this
changed
but you know sometimes life
gives you covered
we're going to get flagged on youtube
this is going to be for sure
how interesting that's not
working
anyway but thanks for hanging out y'all
hope y'all are having a happy
wednesday out there
it's not wednesday
[Laughter]
this whole
thing
this whole thing
oh
yes
this is gonna be a blast covered brain
covered brain
i mean i'm i'm still not all the way
there you know
oh yeah yeah i can imagine
that's my excuse
yeah
i get it that's wow
but okay happy tuesday everyone happy
tuesday
the third day of the week
it is
how are you doing uh yoshi i'm doing
good man i'm doing good i am
excited about the month i got some shows
coming up
been working on the writing
um
just like
trying to make things happen man i feel
like summer's going to be busy
so i'm trying to like
like instead of a summer bot i'm trying
to get like a summer 30 you know i'm
saying like i'm trying to work on a 30
minute like i'm just trying to do like a
lot of
oh
i thought i thought you were saying
summer 30 pounds i thought
i'd love to lose 30 pounds that'd be
great
get back to my
get back to my playing weight
playing what did you play
i'm a ball player son
you playing basketball
yes
oh snap i didn't realize i don't think i
never knew that
yeah man
oh how cool
yeah i love it's really honestly
literally the only thing i do to work
out i i wish i could do other stuff but
i walk but it's that in basketball
hey it adds up
oh for sure
oh and carol than the tub of epsom salt
that i have to get in after
it's
so bad
my knees are just like what are you
doing to us
from playing basketball all those years
yeah i mean just like when i play i'll
play like
two three maybe four hours
so like it's good and i go hard like i'm
i'm in it for
that long and then like afterwards my
body is just like
why why'd you do this to us we didn't we
didn't ask for this
and then the next day it's probably even
worse
oh it's terrible
i'm like just downing just advils and
the leaves and all kinds of stuff
but it's the workout
well
i guess the title is just going to be
the title um
um jaylag said if life gives you covet
make believe it's a government i don't
want to finish that i don't want to get
flagged on i believe it's again
i like that i like i like the computer
that's actually a pretty good joke
but pamela hello pamela
yeah yeah happy tuesday pamela carol's
watching in our facebook group
so this is cool she said my version of
aristocrats would be so they get dad
kissed the mom on the cheek and gently
gave his daughter a side hug and his son
a high five
oh yes i i do remember the aristocrats
yeah
yeah the whole point is just to say like
the most vile
disgusting things possible oh yes the
the family thing just it all just came
back
yeah there's a whole documentary about
it yes
i remember it now
like
and gilbert yeah gilbert just goes in on
it
all right can't post your jokes
everybody oh yeah post your jokes and
i'm gonna act like
the title
being wrong is not bothering me
oh my
gosh it should be so simple
it should right
simple
i said yoshi write 10 minutes on your
knees
is that an aristocrats joke
maybe
i'm like lookie
why would you say such a thing paul's
fam pause
no no i i could write 10 minutes on my
knees of just how like because i've got
like a meniscus tear like oh damn i've
been through all kinds of like but never
took surgery because like i remember uh
i went to the surgeon and he was like
does it like bother you that much
i was like nah he's like then don't do
anything about it i was like that's the
most honest feedback i've ever gotten
from like a doctor like if it doesn't
hurt that bad
just live with it it's like all right
he's like because you don't want to go
into surgery if you don't have to
oh yeah
especially especially at your age it's
so dangerous you know
yeah yeah and this was like
and this was like
oh that was an old age shift man i i'm
over here just like
acting like i'm young
[Laughter]
because this is like
winnie's
i am
oh my gosh don't get it twisted you
getting up there
i i love how you can't even focus
until you get that thing right like
you're you're just like i don't
care about anything that's happening
right now
until this headline is right
nothing is right it doesn't matter it's
just it's the fact that steve called it
out is what really
it's what's really bothering me cause i
was like oh people are noticing the
title is wrong
it's all right you know the people that
are here
they get it
they get it they understand so if you're
watching this and you're like what is
this this is hot breath live we come on
here every tuesday to give y'all joke
feedback
and um discuss
comedy's hottest topics because we're
hot breath
hottest topics
so i must say um welcome aboard everyone
we're so grateful i alright i'm gonna
stop trying to fix this
but why
it's it's kind of like
oh carol said i was having fomo watching
on facebook
since i couldn't see this juicy chat
yeah there's a lot of juicy chat
happening
oh yeah niches muse reference the oscar
slap which uh we we did discuss on here
before
yeah we did and then last week
all i remember about last week's show
is that i was about to fall asleep and
tavis had a really good joke
i don't remember anything we talked
about i don't remember what we said
we're going to talk about this week
but i was i was in the throes of covid
then
i was like deep into it and i couldn't
figure out how to
set up the live stream so i was like all
right we'll just we'll just all do it on
zoom
okay
it doesn't matter what matters is the
quality of the show and it's suffering
because i'm worried about a stupid title
and not hanging out with the people that
are here
so we in here we out here so thanks
everyone for hanging out
yeah um so do post your jokes we'd love
to give you all some feedback on your
jokes
and um
just real quick
um
yoshi and i are based in atlanta
and something that's popping here in
atlanta
is uh
tip
tip t the king the rubber band man
he's doing comedy
and uh it's it's not going great
in some cases i mean
yeah
which is but
to be expected as anyone starting at
comedy that's the best part about comedy
is fame has nothing to do with it like
you can be famous for five minutes but
then after that where are the jokes you
know oh oh that's that's the realest
thing right there yeah and i think the
pro part of the problem is
he's
he's coming out as tip and ti
and he needs to just come out as
clifford harris
that would be interesting
like we need to stop like
stop pretending that you're not like
t.i.p went to jail you know i'm saying
clifford harris like pays taxes
[Laughter]
yeah like just that's what we need to
see because like
he's got is too much baggage
around
seeing
the king of the south like that's too
much to be like oh yeah yeah this is the
king of the south now he wants to try
comedy it's like
no
like the reason and i think what part of
it is like who was it i think uh
kevin hart did the whole chocolate
dropper thing oh that was right
right right it was all comedic and he
was never actually ever
a real rapper that was the whole point
like he actually never did anything good
at rapping the whole time
so it's kind of like me pursuing rap
yes
it almost like hit you all at once yes
that's right
that's right but here's the thing i
would believe that you could pursue rap
because i think you'd take it and you'd
be like yo let me actually work on the
skill set of rapping
ti is completely like
just
trying to make his own rules in the
comedy game like he's going like he went
up after a headliner
already like destroyed a stage
was that was that the one he bombed at
the barclays
no but he did bomb at the barclays but
i actually know people that were at the
show that he did after godfrey went up
in that atlanta comedy theater and it
wasn't good
like he went up after god for atlanta
comedy theater i think so i no it might
not have been the line of comedy theater
but he went up after godfrey wow and
goku
is obese
yeah like you're not there's nothing you
could say
after godfrey just headlines the show
yeah nothing that are open
who's been doing it i think two three
months
like you just don't have those bars
it but it's at every level even like did
you see him at the open mic here in
atlanta where him and lauren knight got
into it
yeah yes
yes
and it's like
first of all
uh
you weren't supposed to do 30 minutes
like that's not okay at an open mic no
one does 30 minutes at an open mic
[Music]
but i think part of it is no one's also
telling him hey don't do 30 minutes at
an open mic
because no one wants to
tell that to ti like no one's be like
hey yo uh mr t.i could you
uh but they would tell me clifford
clifford would do five minutes they
would i would definitely pull over
clifford i was like clifford hey man you
can't be doing no 30 minutes up there
calm down clifford
that's not that's those are there's
different rules to this game clifford
but mookie mookie said
everything you can do wrong is a new
comic he's doing so it's literally i
mean it literally is like
a new comic came in
doesn't know the rules doesn't know the
system
and it's just like i'm going to be a
comedian like literally
anybody could make these mistakes
oh anyone can make these mistakes but
here's what i refuse to believe i refuse
to believe that somebody hasn't told him
and he's like
listening this isn't like oh
i'ma go up and
like someone said to him you got like
when you were given a mic at an open mic
people tell you oh it's five minutes
when you see it's not like he wasn't
there before the open mic and seeing
people do five minutes
seeing the light
behind
and being like oh
uh oh i i wonder what that is i guess
maybe someone's just trying to get their
attention no you know what the light is
you've been to a lot of open mics
but you're it's like it's deliberately
going over your time
but he's doing it because he's ti he's
not doing it like it's just
so like he's bringing his bravado into
the scene and it's like yo
first of all you're not gonna get
funnier that way and you're not gonna
make any friends
but i guess maybe he just doesn't care
it's tough
if you're ti
i mean
you know
yes
it's tough to know
i mean if you're ti it's kind of like
yeah i am entitled to
cut the line a little bit i mean he is
ti
but he is to be funny
you can cut the line all you want
if you bring
hahas right
yeah yeah people people be like hell
yeah ti is in the building y'all he is
about to destroy this he is about to go
after this headline and completely
destroy y'all right give it up for mr
t.i clifford harris pete
we'd all be happy to do that but that's
not what's happening
facts
yeah
but i think like
oh is there wait on my end
oh okay
um but i feel like so what do you what
do you tell ti like what what advice
would you give to ti if ti was to write
hot breath
what advice what are the top three
things you would tell ti to do tomorrow
besides quit
[Music]
besides quit but i think you tell every
comedian to quit
that's true i do do that
i do do that
advice number one quits quick comedy
um
i would tell him to
get a tight five
learn how to write jokes
yeah i would start yeah with
chris o'connor said watch earthquake
everything is on earthquake
the barometer is earthquake now like
he's everywhere
but yeah i mean i would tell yeah you
gotta like start with the fundamentals
and then
kind of
make them your own from there but
i think he's gotta first learn how to
write a joke
you know no no offense to him literally
literally everyone starts here and he
should have an advantage because he's
been riding for so long
and he understood like there's punch
lines and rap and things
even if he told a funny story like i
haven't seen his act honestly like i've
only seen the clips here and there so i
don't know what he's currently doing
but yeah
based on just
comedians reaching out to me in general
i would say like first
get a tight five-minute set together
like whatever you think a tight
five-minute set is like just get five
minutes together not 50
not 30
after a headliner
five minutes it's tight 65.
and it's like
another one would be to like you know
treat
the shows with respect you know don't go
up
like run the light he the thing that he
did with lauren knight he like went up
and like took the mic from her and like
they had this whole back and forth like
that's just something
as a comedian
you don't even think
that that's like appropriate like you
never think i'm going on stage with this
comedian and taking their microphone
you know what i mean
so i would say like write a f type five
minute set to the best of your ability
what that means to you but five minutes
respect the show meaning like don't run
the light don't heckle
don't do any of that
and um the third would be to come on hot
breath and let's talk about it i think
those are the top three
tips yo
if ti gave us his set
we'd make him tight we'd get him so
tight
pause but yeah yeah
we do said reviews
so i mean
we do say review shouting
oh yes for sure yeah i mean and i think
that's that's the key is
like
it feels like no one's in his ear
given him the game of comedy but he's
got connections but he's
he did a show with like david chappelle
like i remember when dave chappelle was
in town
dave chappelle walked in with ti
to the laughing skull
two hours like they're tight and it's
like yo
chappelle get your boy
somebody needs to be like yo get them
get some jokes you know what i mean yeah
i wonder what people are telling him
behind the scenes because i know yeah i
know he knows plenty of comedians who
are who would like tell him
like you know the right way to be doing
things so hopefully these are all just
like
learning
experiences that he's kind of having to
learn
under a microscope because he is ti but
uh hopefully he is getting the right
feedback because i'm
i'm personally rooting for him like i i
want to see him succeed i want to see
him kill it
but
this is the thing everyone is learning
that one everyone that wants to pursue
comedy has to learn
these early struggles of like oh you
mean i don't get a microphone and then a
netflix special you mean there's a whole
there's a whole chasm in between there
so
i'm rooting for him i want him to kill
it and succeed and really put comedy on
an even bigger platform than it's
already on i hope that for him
but he's got to learn the kind of learn
the fundamentals first
yeah for sure but i also think
in the way that he responded to
god free it almost feels like he also
wants to like
make his own lane and write his own
rules about the way that comedy works
and that for me is like you know i i get
that you want to just do your own thing
and you're your own person
but
these laughs still have to happen humor
isn't just you just don't become an
overnight success there are 10-year
successes earthquake is a 30-year
overnight success yeah for sure
you know like you just don't all of a
sudden to your point just get a netflix
special because you're ti you still have
to be funny you still have to be like
relatable and it feels like he's trying
to bypass those things
just because he feels like oh this is
just something that i can get and i
don't know the man personally but it
just i feel like if you have enough
people in your corner rooting for you
someone should be like yo this is the
rules of comedy because obviously
there's rules of rap it's not like a
rapper just overnight just be like
starts rapping and then gets a gets on
grand hustle and has a major deal
is he ever
one like overnight just be like oh yeah
this guy started two months ago rapping
would he sign someone to his record
who's been rapping for two months
right yeah yeah that's a good point
yeah i mean he's doing like the fact
that even took
the barclays gig and was like yo yo
i'mma tell jokes at this huge venue are
you kidding me and then get bomb and
then bomb and then get booed and then he
played a song
because that's the only thing you can do
in that moment
he had to he clifford turned into ti
real quick
yeah he's like play it hit it dj
oh and ryan shrilla said
i hope i pronounced that right ryan i'm
sorry buddy but he came uh he came to
the show at cultivation
uh last time uh he said it's a crazy
time in comedy i'm appreciative of your
pod and guidance not going to worry
about the ti's comedy itself weeds
people out
oh it does and it was a super chat by
the way
nice
give him a super chat horror give him a
power
thanks ryan
very cool there they go
thanks ryan but that's great comedy does
weed itself out i think the hard part is
t.i is such a celebrity like he's one of
those people that now because of this
incident especially with lauren knight
like now people are watching and like
like hoping for something to happen it's
kind of like the slap right it's like
you know everyone's watching what chris
rock is gonna say everyone's watching
every move by will smith like it's like
now you're under that microscope
yeah so
if he doesn't get funny like
soon to your point doesn't get like a
hot type five
it's not gonna go good
unless he like unless he does it more
because i'm sure he's like four moves
ahead i'm sure he has a whole plan i
think he just shot like a movie or a tv
show with a bunch of
i thought you were about to say he just
shot a special special
like i think
i wouldn't be surprised actually
if he's already got a development deal i
mean yeah he's already cooking up a lot
of things i'm sure he's he's talking to
the people that own the building that we
perform at you know i'm saying like
that's different level type stuff like
you mean like yeah he probably has the
mayor's number in his uh rolodex you
know what i'm saying yeah so yeah you're
probably right he's probably thinking
way
way many like steps ahead of us
but you still gotta be funny man you
gotta be it's it's just gotta be funny
it's gotta be funny
yeah uh like dennis thule said comedy
isn't like baseball we don't have minor
league
to prepare comics for the big leagues
everyone has a different path to success
for sure
i mean he's having he's just doing all
this under a microscope so everything he
does
is gonna get blown up but yeah if he's
heckling other comedians it should get
blown up i mean that's that's that's
like
that's just fundamental 101
that's being a good person not heckling
yeah it's just being a good person
yes yeah because this is not the best
those things are going to come out
but that also hurts
your personality from a stage presence
perspective
because if that's who you come out to be
as like
like a-holes in comedy don't make it you
know i'm saying like no one books an
a-hole like yeah
book you if they like you and want to
see you succeed and then want to see you
actually do your jokes in front of their
audience that's how you get booked yeah
but you know comedy owners aren't
booking people they hate or people that
are like
going to berate the crowd
you
yeah william
williams said treat him like any other
comic just starting out be honest and
upfront with him and tell him about hot
breath pro and patreon
we'll send you a promo code t.i yeah
yeah yeah
yeah tiana use these promo codes to get
you get you a class that's what mookie
said look he said take the class
hillary oh mookie said that
yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah it doesn't really stand for
anything i think it's just
uh
it has to right
i don't think it does
chris crystal connor said get that
testimonial from ti hot breath pro
changed my life
changing the game son changing the game
[Laughter]
this is what clifford harris said yeah
i like seeing other people say there are
three things they would tell ti too
that's interesting yeah jlegg said
understand there's a craft all
performing respect the craft of comedy
and respect the audience
jay lake said t.i stands for terrible
improviser oh
my gosh
bars
snap shots fired
sad [__] tavis said ti is the new
brendan shop
i mean
it's like it's like people would throw
shade at brendan schub
he shot a special super quick
it's it's
it's tough because
it's like
don't hate the player hate the game if
the game is putting butts in seats
it's like brendan schaub
jumped way far but
brynden
had access to comedians like joe rogan
which ti has access to the best
comedians in the world
so brendan actually listened to them
and applied what he learned and took it
seriously
he wasn't out taking comedians he like
yeah
he went through he went through the open
mics and all that like he had maybe an
easier path because of who he is but he
still has been putting in the work so so
he will he's still committed to actually
taking it seriously which is not
something
we've really seen from ti yet but
hopefully maybe this will change it
yeah hopefully he watches this
and changes
everything
yeah
chris said this is the comedy equivalent
of jordan retiring and going to play
baseball
very true
very true those are facts
those are facts and i think like we were
talking about before the show like i
think there's sometimes
even if you're good at one thing doesn't
mean you're going to get be good at
another thing
like
yeah
you know me like not every entertainer
should be in crypto you know i'm saying
like i get it
yeah
but like what do you know about finance
or what do you know about bitcoin right
it's like
yo like not everything is suited
to be marketed or like you can just get
into because
you're good at one thing
big facts
oh well we're good uh bobby said tell ti
the room is only open for so many
minutes step on another comic's minutes
they may step on you
as you try to climb
the comedy ladder of success
yeah
ryan said i wouldn't hate to get slapped
by ti i could use the views dude if i
got slapped by ti just know i won't be
on the show next week
we're going to be in the maldives
if i get slapped
[Laughter]
so are you are you for it like what what
is your take are you are you four or
five percent i want you
to do what are you for ti like pursuing
comedy oh yeah i want him to be
successful
i just believe
that
you do have to follow the human rules of
comedy of like not heckling not being an
a-hole
like
those are just common everyday rules
that still applies to comedy like not
disrespecting the light not like
coming to the shows with like
in essence like
i get like if you come to the show with
like people to protect you from a
personal perspective but like also maybe
bring a comedian friend
like bring an advisor like i i'm just so
surprised that he comes to shows and
there's not a comedy person next to him
just being like
you know hey
that was a good set because it feels
like no one's telling him
that he's not doing it in the right way
or like he's not doing it in
like whatever he's doing
like it's as if though no one's like
advising him and it's like yo your ti
you can afford a consultant
i'm sure he's been getting consulting
maybe now more than ever as people like
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa bro whoa whoa
whoa whoa
[Laughter]
so yeah i'll be i'll be interested to
see what comes of it but i'm i'm hoping
you know these are just those early
growing pains that we all have to go
through as comedians that i'm hoping
we're gonna start to see
some more you know some more uh what we
call them in comedy uh jokes that's
right jokes
what's that thing that we used to do
back in the day oh yeah
jokes set up punchline oh
much like but i hope nothing but the
best for him i hope it really does work
out for him because it's just it'll be
another avenue for people to find
comedians and i'm sure he would use it
as a way
to
um put other comedians on as well oh for
sure yeah and i think i'm hoping the
best that's that's the opportunity for
him to like make that leap and
definitely close the gap because you
know at the end of the day like ryan
said we're like we're all artists this
is all an art we all want approval from
people to be like yo i vibe with you i
like what you're doing on stage we're
all attention [__] here let's let's
not get a twist
i know what this is
and i understand it um but yeah and i i
definitely want him to be successful but
you know
i don't
i just don't
you know there's just some rules to this
game
and you gotta be funny
like that's the other thing like if it's
constant that you're not funny and then
you're breaking all the rules it's like
what are we doing
[Laughter]
valid point yeah if we're not doing
jokes what are we doing
nice the ip really stinks for 10 inch
player
eclipse lawn care just googled it he
said
yeah that facts
i don't know man
that's funny though oh william's rooting
for him as well he just said he needs a
mr miyagi
to uh teach him how to wax on and wax
off
hopefully i i mean i'm sure
he needs a help he needs a hot breath
consultant package right that's what he
needs
that's what he needs yeah that's what he
needs we're here for your ti we're here
to help we are here for you buddy
all right
mr harris if you need anything holler at
us clifford but i think the takeaway is
change your name to clifford and it'll
change a lot
it'll change a lot like because no one
wants to see ti on stage no one would
ever see i sing on stage but people need
to see clifford
because clifford can do like america's
got talent t.i can do america's got
talent yeah yeah yeah yeah jokes i think
it would be like a mindset shift for him
too because
he's not going as ti but lismore
but i mean it's ti he'll probably just
stay as ti it's a brand and all that
i want to see clifford do comedy though
i think that really
that really takes away a lot of the bite
it takes like imagine a comedy special
called clifford does comedy
oh my gosh
that's hilarious
[Laughter]
i'd watch it for sure
but it's a hot topic that i'm sure will
continue to evolve but um
we're rooting for him we're rooting for
clifford
he's just learning that's how everybody
everybody's got to learn
yeah
i just love
that's what i love about comedy the most
though is that there's no one is immune
to any of the like the struggles
oh no ti kingdom
it's the equalizer that stage
equalizes you it gets you
it gets honest because people
and what they laugh at
is the most honest thing
and if it's not funny they're not going
to laugh yep
period yeah like you said the the appeal
would be like for like five maybe five
ten minutes
oh look it's ti on stage after that
you better come with these jokes facts
big facts shouty
well hopefully he does or he comes on
a hot breath william said we should
tweet at him
to
to get on hot breath and join our comedy
cult
oh my god
clifford let's go
not a bad idea hey it worked for bert
kreischer why not do it for ti
bart
we're still gonna get burnt i'm not i
haven't given up on bert we are we're
never getting burnt oh we're definitely
getting burnt i'm not worried about it
we should bring bert and clifford on
that's
facts at the same damn time
let's uh let's do some joke feedback
here um
i think we have um
is bobby the first one
bobby my jokes is she the first
let me scroll up
uh we appreciate all y'all hanging out
here thanks everyone we love you all so
much and thanks for sharing your insight
on uh the ti situation because it is it
affects all of us so
it's definitely um
something that will hopefully evolve and
continue to get better
and not just become more just headlines
of like oh what did ti do now you know i
really want it to be something that can
become like a positive impact on the
comedy game
for sure like i want to see the meme
where somebody says t.i was killing the
crowd
yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure
for shizzle
so let's see i'm sorry i can't get past
ryan's super chat thank you so much ryan
i mean that's all i really see is ryan
putting some putting some love in the
tip jar for this
thank you so much ryan that's what i'm
seeing out here
but um
[Laughter]
it always makes my heart smile and my
wife's
um
it's so funny dude so let's let's get
into your jokes here everyone
um
i think it may be bobby bobby may be
first here
yeah
uh let's see
first joke up
um
trying to till a garden on a decade's
abandoned farm
found so many snake holes in the rear i
figured this place was either a
whorehouse or a pentecostal church
[Music]
on a decade's abandoned farm found so
many snake coals in the rear
um yikes
i
i i like the joke i mean i think it
could probably
uh
the snake holes in the rear i don't get
because that maybe that's a farm term
but just i got it just by saying i found
a lot of snake holes i figured this
place
was either a whorehouse or a pentecostal
church the only thing i would do is just
relate it more to personal
and just say hey i've been trying to
till a garden on a decade's
farm abandoned farm
and then just
so like that that'd be the only thing
i'd add to this but i like it like i
almost think some tags after the
pentecostal church or like an act out
after the pentecostal church thing would
be very funny after this joke
oh yeah yeah i could see this in bobby's
voice too of like
when she gets like really excited or she
like
really raises her voice
and then like builds on the absurdity of
it of like it was either a whorehouse or
a pentecostal church like you know like
the highest you can get with it
because that's
[Laughter]
yeah i like that too
oh did you get my coved over there did
you call him
you got that loud oh did you feel you
feeling kind of sick
oh i mean i've been feeling kind of i
mean i got kids dude i'm always sick
like
just all kinds of stuff do you like it's
a school year
parents are going to be sick like your
house is a peach treat petri dish oh
right they just bring home everything
all kinds of stuff
like foot mouth disease like all kinds
it's just wildness dude it's wild
thank you
oh nice well thank you thanks for
posting there bobby oh and jones in here
hey joan
she said it was a nice surprise she
didn't expect to see us oh yay hey we
out here
bobby said her husband's laughing at my
imitation of him
or imitation of her
hilarious
it's true though it's yeah the more it
almost seems like the more excited or
passionate
your body delivers it the funnier it
gets
yes yeah yeah yeah
because she just has one of those it's
like we kind of talk about gilbert
godfrey
and his identifiable voice i mean you
can hear bobby and know it's bobby you
know which is yeah
what we all strive to have so yeah
um and then just and you're playing into
your own persona too which is important
that you understand your awards and then
use it to your advantage on a stage
[Music]
so let's see here sasha
here we go okay
and peeps go ahead and post your jokes
in the comments if you'd like some
feedback on a joke
yeah
my wife and i don't want kids and that
really disappoints our parents
at this point they're looking at us like
nascar just hoping for an accident
all right
um
i get it i'm wondering if like the
surprise could be bigger
my wife and i
don't want kids
and that really disappoints our parents
at this point they're looking at us like
nascar
uh yeah i think it could be tighter in
terms of like an analogy
there's there's a lot to unpack it's
like my wife and i don't want kids that
really disappoints our parents
it's
if there's a way to simplify it
yeah i mean you could just rearrange
that like our parents are disappointed
that my wife and i don't want kids
oh that's the second
oh yeah
yeah yeah
good call
you said that so matter of fact yeah
dude you just flip it
that makes it flow more conversationally
too yeah yeah
um
and then yeah just they're looking at us
like
nascar
hoping for an accident but i think what
it is is like
i don't get the accident part in terms
of
what they're expecting
oh
now i get it
right yes you watch nascar hoping
there's a crash an accident yeah yeah
okay okay
i i like just rearranging it a little
bit you did i don't i think it works
i it doesn't it
i mean it doesn't kill like it doesn't
feel like this would kill
you know maybe maybe we could sell this
joke to ti or something um
but
[Music]
except ti would be like they're hoping
for a nascar accident and i've already
had seven of them so right yeah yeah
like like like my last set is what he
would say
[Laughter]
um
and looking at
us like i think what i'm wondering is
like is there anything else about nascar
that could be it like almost like
no left turns or like
barely any black people you'll say like
i i think i just want a different kind
of surprise
like but i'm trying to think that even
with the accident you just you need to
know nascar to get the joke
you need to know people are watching it
hoping to see a car crash
so it is dependent on that
it is dependent on that i think that's
what it is it's like
i just know right nascar is car racing
like i'm into it but i'm not like
into it like that so
i thought people were watching it
because
there's nothing else to do
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
but yeah i don't think it's nick he
basically asked is it hack or not i
don't think it's hacked
crack
i think you just gotta be clearer on
hmm
oh tavis had a good
tag he said
and i'd do it but they refused to
sponsor us
i don't hate that and sasha said he
bought this joke from t.i
so
bobby said crashing it to the pit
yeah i like that tag from tavis really i
don't i mean i think you know
i think the i think the joke works i
think
redoing it to
be like our parents are disappointed we
don't want kids
yeah uh at this point they're looking at
us like nascar
just hoping for an accident i think i
think it works
yeah
i'm trying to think just what else is an
accident that you could use
like it like a synonym
yeah
like what else
like what other references
are you hoping for an accident
you mean like a wreck like a crash
yeah even
like even there
but the accident plays in with kids as
well
because like a kid being an accident you
know
yeah yeah yeah
yeah i can't think of it but yeah i i i
think
you do have to know the references for
it to pop
right and i just don't know i just don't
know nascar like that
yeah i don't i don't hate it there sasha
i don't hate it thanks for sharing
uh let's see
this may be
let me see
i this may be william let me see
going to our facebook group
yes this is william
um
years ago i joined a men's group to make
friends god heard me say 150 new naked
male friends dancing around a fire
um
i guess you need to know what a men's
group is
yes
god heard me
yeah yeah i'm gonna
i'm waiting for the punch line
and i don't know if it's just it feels
like you're just surprising us with that
male friends are dancing around a fire
and that's doesn't feel like a strong
enough punch
or or say something like he heard my
prayers
like or i prayed for more friends
but yeah i mean even that would work but
like
years ago i joined the men's group to
make friends
god heard me say 150
new naked male friends down syndrome
maybe it's yeah it's a connection i
prayed i prayed for more friends
and ended up in a men's group maybe
apparently god thought i said
150 new naked
male friends dancing around a
fire hmm
yeah
i think that's definitely much clearer
for sure i think that's what it is
there's too many assumptions in this
joke
you have to know too many things
you have to know what a men's group is
you got to know
like the prayer set like it just feels
like there's too many
like
um
simplify it right yeah
yeah you gotta simplify
so something more like i
i prayed for more friends and ended up
in a men's group
apparently god thought i
said
a hundred and
new naked
quitting
comedy maybe we can throw this to ti2
that's what eclipse lawn care said he
bought that joke from ti as well
[Music]
hope that helps there william
all right
let's do a let's do some more here
i'm supposed to go plant some plants
with my wife
so nice and let's um
let's let's keep it tight just for her
let's get it gone for like two weeks
um
your plant quota is just
oh best believe his movement she went
shopping
let's believe there's more plants out
there
but i enjoy it i i actually do enjoy it
[Music]
my voice that's what you get
yep i enjoy it
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
everything she does i enjoy but it's
true i do i actually do enjoy the plan
you're sure
yeah
yep
i do though i really do i seriously do
i actually do enjoy it i'm so messy with
it it's working
[Laughter]
i'll just be there
all right carol freeman i'm a keto coach
and not that strict with it but some act
like it's a religion they want to
replace hotel bibles with thick cut
bacon and all dollar bills to say in
lard we trust
all right
i like it i see where you're going
uh
i think it's got too many beats to it
and it just needs to be simplified
um
i like the i'm a keto coach
part i think the only thing about
this joke is you almost have to
know what keto is
to then get
the thick cut bacon the bacon and the
the lard yeah
it's true
but for the joke it could just be
um
people treat keto like a religion they
want to replace hotel bibles with bacon
but like just just to like rework this
joke you know but um
yeah but i like that though i like it
because i think that you can just then
you can add more to it like
in lord we trust
in uh
pig feet 4
19 right
right like
the bible verses
uh with references to swine you know
saying or like in swine
2 4
in lord we trust yeah
jacob jacob said i would love to see a
king james apple apple smoked
[Laughter]
i think with the analogy set up
i think there's a lot that can be done
with it
oh like keto being a religion
you know
and like it's like they uh
communion is
whatever is keto you know or uh
the lord's supper
yeah
becomes like pork grinds or something
like that or
uh right bacon
yeah whatever's specific to keto which
i'd i mean i've heard of keto
but yeah
yeah thinking of a in a venn diagram
something we talk about on here all the
time a venn diagram is a great place to
start with this and you just have
a column for keto and you have a column
for like religion and in the middle you
have a column for like the parallels
between the two
and just kind of brainstorm a bunch of
different connections because i love the
analogy
yeah
that king james apple smoked is very
funny yeah i think so
yeah yeah
you can use bible verses you can use
yeah king james
apple smoked you can use um just more
even just more references to
like joel said just
uh religion
and
bacon
yeah yeah yeah like just what do those
two things have
with it
i like it though i love the analogy
is that jlegg said ti stand up killed
yeah oh
no
moving on
my voice is kind of going
i'm interesting
did not expect this
you're welcome carol
nice
um
oh yeah loaves turn water to wine
turn water to swine
or like or what's a keto drink or
something like there's so many different
there's so many parallels there i i love
that premise though
turn water to swine
that's hilarious
[Laughter]
um
who's next here
you know some would say i'm pretty funny
you know
some would say back in my day
back in my day
i could do it that guy
uh
john
samuel where are you seeing john are you
seeing john just slower
oh he's lower
yeah
um
who did i read the last one
i did
okay
oh and
the swine line was turned water to swine
carol like water to wine but watered
sweat
okay
um
samuel i lost my father when i was just
a little boy it was terrible
thought knowing he was out there all
alone surrounded by water
he was lost at sea world
[Laughter]
gotcha
um
when i was a little boy i lost my father
fortunately
he was wearing
a life alert
or fortunately
he was on a fortunately i was on a leash
basically the misdirect is
the setup is you lost him like he died
but you really just lost him somewhere
public yeah
so i don't i don't think
we need all the filler of
oh nice
tavis said he was lost at sea
paws world
yeah that's pretty solid
i don't hate it
nope that's solid
oh eden's here what's up
even eden what they missed we talked
about ti for a bit
uh
and now we're doing joke feedback
yep
and my wife is in the other room like he
said he'd be done at six
[Music]
uh but the hot breath of hers honey
i get a super chat today baby yeah we
got a super
i'm making five dollars an hour honey
come on
[Laughter]
hilarious um
uh where'd we go
but yeah i think we got that one right
yeah yeah we did
just let me tighten it up yep just a
nice little edit there and you're there
my friend um
john mondragon
dragon is that who's next
where'd he go there he is
john
hmm
all right i went on a date last week
with a girl
that was so out of my league that i ran
the red light camera intersection taking
her back home just to get the picture to
show my friends
we're both reading it like to ourselves
like all right wait
did we miss something or did john just
miss
i like the premise
yes
the premise is there
there's just not a punch line
because really what you're telling us is
what you did to go show your pictures
show her pictures back to your friends
so
if the punch line is
um
i feel like the punch line is more that
you ran a red light camera
like you ran a red light
like i dot i
so
if you went back home to show a picture
of your friends
i like that premise but i think i'm
wondering like
i went on a date last week with the
store out of my league
i attempted to go back home to show my
friends and got pulled over
so i showed the picture to the cop
instead
you and me like
like that's how excited you were
chris said i didn't want to be weird
taking a picture so i ran the red light
camera to get a picture to take home
or it's like or it could be like you did
it as evidence that you actually went on
a date with her
um
it feels this feels like a sketch
yeah
like this feels like it would be a funny
sketch
uh but also i think you have to act this
out
like so i ran the red light camera
so i could take a picture
of her to show my friends
like you almost have to you got to find
a way to act out
because i just thought you just ran a
red light
i just got the fact that
that was the picture that you took to
show your friends
right
so for me it just wasn't clear
when you took the picture
until like now
john said he does the act out yeah or
like my friends didn't believe me
so i showed them
uh
i showed them a picture of me getting
getting arrested with her or something
like that like i feel like it just gotta
be my yeah the mug shot with her
with her and i as we you know yeah so i
showed
yeah i showed my friends our mug shot
yeah that's not bad
but maybe there's something that's
out of our league
or out of my league maybe there's
another way to say that
that has more
criminal implications
to kind of play into it you know
uh
running on foot
maybe she didn't want to be seen
maybe she didn't want to be seen with me
so i ran a red light to get the photo
i even think like i went on a date last
week with a girl that was just
killer that i ran a red light
or like i broke a law like
yeah maybe just a reference to
how hot she is
i think
maybe you said this earlier
the punch line is the red light camera
yes
so
it's almost like it needs to end on that
yep so she was so out of his league
in order to get a picture
i ran the red light camera
yeah
like something like that to where it
ends on
red light camera being the punch line
you know
oh people throwing in some ideas here
though this is great
people
people exercising their joke muscles
today this is great
andrew said she was so out of my league
i drove the car off a cliff so when they
found our bodies they'd know i could
slang the d
joke is solved uh i think that's it
right there
if we get give
let's give andrew our super chat let's
give him can we give him half of our
super chat for that
william said uh i'm dating a woman out
of my league i ran a red light so the
300 ticket would be proof of my date
bobby said i ran a camera light to prove
to my friends
that i hadn't kidnapped the girl that
was so out of my league
carol said i went on a date with a hot
girl last week but my friends didn't
believe me so for our second date i'm
planning on getting a photo
by running a red light
yeah
[Music]
i don't hate that
i don't hate that either i don't hate
that at all
yeah because it ends
that's what we're trying to get to is it
ending on that
the punch line yep like carol may have
cracked it there actually i don't hate
that at all
look at you carol keto carol
good call i like that
i like that i think she i think that's
it
it does awesome
good stuff
all right are there any others
[Music]
well goodness this was a goodie
yeah
all right
well thanks everyone for hanging out
oh cool
oh it just showed i'm logged in i was
trying to log into a different youtube
so i could edit the title of this video
i'm currently logged into mine
my personal
but um
it's it was pulsing the um
the super chat i didn't know it did that
like at the bottom of the chat
there's like there's the dollar bill
and it was like flashing it like show
support to the show i didn't know it did
that
i thought people just didn't know how to
super chat
but they just don't care i guess that's
what it is um
no i'm just kidding
[Laughter]
nah it's all jokes it's all love my
friends
this was a good one
yes i feel good about this one i think
we had a good chat about t.i too
had some good jokes in here
this show just keeps getting better and
better
that's funny
oh thank you thank you j legg so thanks
guys see you next week yeah yeah
oh yeah
yeah i'm uh
oh thank you andrew
andrew said
thanks joel you the best
yoshi's pretty good too we can give
yoshi some cred there he had a really
good idea for tiata performance clifford
i really like that
that's a really good idea
for the
comedian
yeah
what i want to say we talked about
gilbert godfried at the beginning of
this
yeah for anyone that's just tuning in um
all right all right all right peter
gilbert yes
no longer with us
but uh
yeah
we out man i guess that's it i hate to
end on that but goodness gracious wait a
minute yeah
sometimes
it's just what it is this is a good one
though
here
thanks everyone
bye y'all
angel's on y'all
have a good day
i'll be good bye people
bye
we'll see you tomorrow
wednesday tomorrow at 10 a.m i'm doing
the right tank club live we're gonna and
we're gonna fix the label yep yep it's
all gonna be fixed by then it's not
gonna be fixed but
y'all